fibromyalgia is a chronic disorder that
affects at least 5 million Americans
mostly women it's characterized by non
restorative sleep and muscle aches and
stiffness that may last all day
pain in all four quadrants of the body
and the presence of specific tender
points while fibromyalgia pain can vary
in intensity sufferers often describe it
as a deep persistent ache or a stabbing
or shooting muscular pain other common
symptoms include incapacitating fatigue
insomnia joint pain leg cramps headaches
and concentration and memory problems
known as fibro fog
because there is no lab test or x-ray to
confirm a diagnosis of fibromyalgia some
patients were once led to believe this
pain was all in their heads today many
researchers think the brain and spinal
cord process pain messages incorrectly
causing fibromyalgia patients to feel
pain more intensely
one of the unique aspects of
fibromyalgia is the presence of tender
points in specific locations on the body
when these points are pressed people
with fibromyalgia feel pain while people
without the syndrome only feel pressure
to be diagnosed with fibromyalgia a
patient must be sensitive in at least 11
of the 18 possible tender points and
experience widespread pain in all four
quadrants of the body